[Musik]
entschuldigen sie dass ich sie störe sie
nicht
bitte setzen sie sich ich habe leider
nicht viel zeit
ich habe kurzfristig zwei tickets für
eine spannende kulturveranstaltung in
der stadt bekommen
es wird eine sehr interessante
ausstellung geben und ein neues
theaterstück aufgeführt
danach gibt es noch einen tollen film
kino das klingt saison ja das ist auch
sehr interessant weil die ausstellung
das aktuelle thema flucht und heimat
haben
und ich dachte es wäre vielleicht schön
wenn sie mich begleitet hat doch wo
leute keine zeit dahin
du sollst es selber gehen lassen
also mich würde interessieren wobei ich
dir helfen soll weil ich deine eltern
gerade eiskalt an lügen musste
es tut mir leid dass bei einer neuen
krise ich muss zu nico weiß wo er ist
hier kommen wir müssen uns beeilen